non-minimalists
i remember that josh mentioned in the
previous episode that it's important to
have
a partner with a similar sex driver
libido even if you have a partner with
an aligned sex drive
how can one apply minimalism to either
increase or decrease
the sex that is going on in your
relationship so
in the past i think i've mentioned that
my wife and i have similar sex drives
and that's really good for our
relationship i'm certainly not
um mapping that on to every relationship
i'm sure there are some relationships in
which
there are radically different sex drives
although i think that would probably
cause some tension so
can we talk about libido's role in a
relationship and i think maybe that's
leading to all some of these
porn problems that we're having where
one person may have an appreciably
different
libido from their partner yeah i think
some of it starts from
comfort where you become a little bit
complacent and then maybe a little bit
lazy
right and then you have to roll that
back in and say to yourself oh i
remember how excited i was when we first
moved in together
and i knew we could have sex whenever we
wanted as opposed to
when we went on our date on friday or
saturday night right
having those thoughts in your mind and
reminding yourself of that excitement
and and kind of finding that way to
spark that
and connect that without being too
intrusive right because sometimes
someone gets home they're exhausted
you're not in sync but one of you is
ready and the other isn't
setting that stage how do people set
that stage
i tell a lot of my guy friends if your
girl's working late and you're afraid
that this might be a night where it
doesn't happen make sure you like tidy
up the place before she gets home
do little things so that when she gets
home her mind has less weight
and she is free and also she's turned on
by that
she's excited by that she was driving
home thinking about all these little
chores she was going to do now she
doesn't
now here you are it can be a simple
candle can be it was a wedding gift i
always buy the bride and the groom a
cologne and a perfume that i tell them
to never wear
anywhere except they wear it on their
wedding day and then they wear it at
home on special like as a
as a scent trigger of like let's get at
it tonight you know what i mean
don't wear on a regular thing don't
worry about a date to go out to dinner
only in your home
yeah that's so good that scent reminds
you of that day yeah
well i think too like he's out he asks
how can minimalism help you
have more sex in the in in your
relationship um
going back to you know we're just trying
to help people find a middle ground
yeah so uh how going to your partner
going to your
uh wife or husband or whatever and
saying hey look um
here is my values when it is when it
comes to sex here
are my desires and you start that
conversation and see
exactly how maybe you two can get on the
same page now maybe one partner does
have a higher libido than the other
so then the question is is go out of
your you know how can you go out of your
way
to show your partner that you want to do
everything that you can for them to make
them be
uh in a sexual mood i know like with
with with my partner like i will um
ask her you know hey what what what can
i do for you i don't like talking about
our sex life too much like but but this
is an appropriate time i guess to talk
about it
but uh you know it'll be something like
she'd be like you know i really want you
to like pick out a nice pair of shorts
for me or uh or or a nice
a nice like lingerie thing for me or um
hey let's pick out a sex toy together
and like those things uh i pay attention
to um if i didn't ask her
i wouldn't know to do that thing so so
let's let's talk a bit about
libido and and its role in
a good relationship a healthy
relationship with
a partner um i think sometimes it's one
of those weird things where
we feel like we can't talk about our
desires
even with the people closest to us or
maybe even especially
with the people closest to us and
and i think that that creates some
tension in the relationship if i were to
get back to ari's question here
maybe i would say you know at least in
my own relationship one thing that has
helped us
is uh becks will often pick a porn for
us to watch
and so it often is the more sensual
woman directed exactly what you were
talking about earlier
and in doing that it helps me better
understand you know even though we have
similar libidos we obviously have
different preferences
and it helps me understand her
preferences what works for her
and then communicating is really key i
can't tell you how many
relationships i was in before this
relationship
i communicated really well in every area
except sex
and i i'm not sure why that is
you two probably have a more honest
connection and the fact that maybe women
in the past
felt like they wanted to put a porn on
but they didn't know how you would feel
about it and then they overthought it
and then they just refused to do it
right
she feels comfortable enough with you
that sets the stage it shows you
something different it's a little bit of
like
even the bad music in the background of
a porno it gets you kind of it's just
like it's it's a dragon thing right it's
not great music but
it gets you there you might even need
none of you fully focused watching it
it's just starting it and igniting that
maybe that conversation they didn't feel
comfortable enough having people are
very held back by
being open and honest about their libido
and what they want
for you the little shopping trips the
little details the tiny things that's a
kickstarter
i think the most important thing is not
letting it go too long before you have
the conversation you know people will
say oh we haven't had sex in months
okay well at what point do you decide to
not go sit outside somewhere at a park
and talk about it shouldn't be something
you can't talk about but get away from
all your stuff
i always tie nature in with
communication because i think sitting
outside
can really clear you of all the
pressures in your home your mail your
laundry your stuff
go sit outside at a park put your phones
in the car
talk about this let's get this ball
rolling you love each other
you want to touch each other you don't
want someone else touch you you don't
want to watch pouring behind each
other's back
right right you want to do this together
so you have to really work at that
yeah i think there was a part in a time
in my first marriage where
um things were just weren't working we
weren't compatible she's
a great person it just didn't work out
for us
and that did start happening where we
weren't watching porn together it was
like i'm going to watch this when you're
not home
yeah which is a huge failure right yeah
a huge failure
absolutely was and and instead of
communicating you know dan savage calls
it a former podcast guest of ours he
calls it ggg good
giving and game when you're in a
relationship you want to be
good at whatever you're doing or trying
to get better at it
in order to please the other person uh
giving
means you're not just receiving that's
often a a problem especially many men
have is uh being the receiver but never
the giver
and and then of course game you're
willing to do anything within reason
sure right and that's going to be
different for each person reason
can be way way over here for one person
and but but
being willing to sort of expand those
boundaries together
i found has really our sex life now
we've been together over five years it's
way better than it was when it even
started
and that's the opposite from virtually
any relationship
i've ever been in actually it's
definitely the opposite of any
relationship i've been in
and and so it tends to wane over time in
many relationships because
you have that chemistry early on right
there's the early chemistry
but then the rest of the relationship
sort of you you get comfortable and that
chemistry
yeah yeah and so i think if anything
ari um what you're looking for is that
that good giving and game
helps you avoid that complacency which
is so important all right i'm gonna send
you a copy of our book everything that
remains there's a chapter in there
about how to screw up a relationship
it's uh
the first love of my life i really
screwed up and
uh right right and uh and i wrote about
the lessons i learned from that so
it's a memoir called everything that
remains uh ryan and i wrote it
a few years ago and if you like our
podcast you'll like the audiobook
version of everything that remains or if
you want the book book or the ebook
version
happy to send those to you as well
you